19 response teams have fanned out across
indirapuram
a neighboring town to the national
capital delhi
their task to screen and survey over 200
the woman's husband tested positive and
the family is in home
a covert 19 sticker on their wall
indicates the fight with the contagion
is still on and all help a phone call
away
his neighbor has developed a dry cough
the team checks his fever and tells him
to get a test
immediately
the team must screen all families living
within a hundred meter radius
of a positive case
this is very important for awareness
people will be alert
these teams are coming to our homes to
inform and check on us
it's very encouraging and makes a big
difference
india has ramped up its testing
capabilities
now over a million people are tested
every day
but it's the poor who are most
vulnerable they would lose out on a
day's work
if they had to go to a hospital so the
mobile clinic
comes to them results of a rapid antigen
test
are out within 15 minutes its accuracy
may be contested
but it does help isolate people carrying
the virus
india's fatality rate is less than two
percent one of the lowest in the world
but the concern here is that the public
health care system
is inadequate in most parts of the
country especially
rural india in some places it's
non-existent
india had one of the severest lockdowns
for months
but now with the graded unlocking it has
the fastest rate of infection
anywhere in the world the virus has
denied
all of a suitable final ritual
indispensable to the grieving
families a favor from afar